um the first thing I want to say is
everybody in the Nights Watch is losing
weight they're getting stronger Sam is
not you might be getting my question is
if the number of pages wasn't an issue
it kinda doesn't seem to me but if you
could write even more is there a minor
character you know it's between minor
and major that if you could have given
more about his background developed him
more that you would have done that for
it well I'm not sure I think looking at
what what the show is doing second
season one of the things that they've
done is expand on Rob's adventures in
the West considerably you know in in the
book I don't have Rob is not a viewpoint
character ever in the books and his his
story is presented primarily through the
viewpoint of Catlin when he's in the
south and earlier parts of it partly
through the viewpoint of brand when he's
still at Winterfell
so when Rob goes west and has his
battles with the Lannisters and his
encounter with Jeyne Westerling and so
forth and and some very important things
happen there and we just hear about them
through Raven reports and so forth if I
had it to do over again I might go back
and change that and and promote Rob to a
full-fledge viewpoint character and you
know add a whole sequence of chapters
where we would actually see that happen
in the in the north I could see gaining
something from that again if as you say
pages weren't an issue cuz that would
probably add another 100 pages at least
to a book that's already 1200 pages long
in manuscript but it also has some
negative effects of course I mean the
way the book reads currently you don't
know what's Rob's up to so when Rob
actually comes back to Riverrun and and
you know you hear what he's done from
from Kats viewpoint it has enormous
impact because it comes as a total shock
to her and therefore to the reader who's
learning these stories alert you blunt
that if you introduce him as a viewpoint
character so you have to weigh those
kind of options together just and that's
a that's an interesting thing there have
been places in the in the books where I
have wished maybe I should switch to the
viewpoint character of the sand such
here and I don't because I can't see
following I don't want to I don't want
to switch viewpoint just to have a pair
of eyes at a battle and then the
character is not important
and he fades out very quickly or he
becomes a useless kind of character
where he's just observing things I I
think each of my viewpoint characters
I'm trying to tell a story about them
yeah you know it's a good thing these
books are published occasionally or I
would keep revising them forever my
effort to achieve some sort of platonic
perfection and the problem is there is
no such thing as platonic affection so I
make a choice and I have to live with it
and maybe I regret it later and I change
it if it the book is still in progress
then I change it back to you first way
because I changed my mind again you know
the the one character the one viewpoint
character that I wonder whether I should
have made him a viewpoint character is
eros oak cart in a feast for crows
because he's only a viewpoint character
for a single chapter and I look at that
maybe I should have presented that from
Ariana's viewpoint you know because the
scene is mostly Ariane and ands or eros
but I wanted to show what was going on
through his head and why he made the
decision that he made which was which I
thought was important but since he is a
viewpoint character for only that single
chapter maybe I should have refrained
from making him a viewpoint character it
hmm I don't know now did the ring but
that's the sort of image I go through my
head when I'm when I'm wrestling with
these with these issues some people have
also pointed out that maybe I should
have a Dothraki
character and that's something I've
considered Minh interesting idea you
know as it is I'm presenting that
culture from outside from from the
viewpoint of someone who's very alien to
it and and you know Danny comes to
understand certain aspects of it but
never never really completely as someone
born in the culture would do so maybe I
should have done that as well but I
didn't so they were